my name is Taylor Spivey
I'm from Redondo Beach California and
I'm ranked fourth in the world and the
IT triathlon series when I'm racing I
kind of don't really think about too
much I'm just in the moment it's a
pretty cool state of mind because I
don't think I really experience it
anywhere else outside of racing my first
year in triathlon I had a very bad bike
crash I was on a group ride with my dad
it was actually his birthday and I had a
bump in the road and I fell down
I broke my hand in two places got nine
stitches in my elbow I had a lot of road
rash on my entire left side and the
worst injury was in my knee I could see
my kneecap when I saw my knee injury I
really didn't think I could ever do
traffic again the first few weeks after
or pretty rough I spent almost every day
going to physical therapy it took me
about two months to learn how to walk
again as my body started to heal I
noticed that I wasn't quite able to bend
my knee as easily as I could before so
it took a lot of time to get that
flexibility back because I think I was
missing some tissue something that
traumatic will continue to affect me the
rest of my life I'm fortunate that it's
really mild and I can you know keep
these aches and pains that fade
[Music]
it taught me to be hyper-vigilant on the
bike I think I see things before they
have to know it can be dangerous at
times and anything can happen and it
makes me feel as safe as I possibly can
I'm so happy I was able to overcome that
injury and continue to swim bike and run
and the caliber I'm at now I I think in
that moment I think out my career was
done so it's pretty cool to see that I
was able to overcome an obstacle like
that
[Music]